PETE: So we're extremely
excited to welcome
our speaker today, Sophie Egan.
Sophie grew up here
in the Seattle area,
and she currently works at the
Culinary Institute of America
as the Director of Programs
and Culinary Nutrition
for the Strategic
Initiatives Group.
She graduated from
Stanford where
she studied math and history and
competed on a triathlon team.
She completed her master's
in public health at Berkeley.
Since then, she's been writing
for "Sunset" magazine, "Wired"
magazine, and "The New
York Times'" "Well Blog."
I'm personally excited because
I found her book fascinating.
It was full of things that
were relevant, interesting,
and that I hadn't heard before.
And I had problems putting
it down the same way
I have problems putting down
a science fiction novel.
So let's welcome Sophie.
[APPLAUSE]
SOPHIE EGAN: Thank
you so much, Pete.
Can you hear me?
Can you hear me in the back?
Yes.
Thank you so much, Pete.
That's a terrific
introduction, and certainly
the highest praise
I could hear is
to be compared to
science fiction.
I also-- with the
title of the book--
hoped that with all of the fan
fiction around vampire books,
maybe someone would accidentally
buy my book thinking that it
was about vampire romance.
So in any case, I'm
really excited to be here
at Google and just
back in Seattle.
As Pete mentioned,
I'm a Seattle native.
I swear this place gets
more spectacularly beautiful
every time I come home.
And I'm really
thrilled to take you
on a little journey
today, a journey
into the American food psyche.
So as we know, the
United States is home
to innovations of all kinds.
I mean, we're sitting
at Google, right?
We invented the polio
vaccine, the iPhone,
and the Doritos Locos taco.
For those of you
who don't know, this
was actually one of the
bestselling fast food
items of all time.
We collectively as Americans
ate 100 million of them
in 10 weeks.
It took McDonald's 10 years to
reach that number with the Big
Mac.
And we sustained that pace
at about a million per day
through the first year.
And so all of the R&D that
took place down at Taco Bell,
three times the length of
the normal new food product,
really paid off.
I actually had the pleasure of
visiting Taco Bell headquarters
and met with some of
the food scientists
behind this offspring of
Frito Lay and Taco Bell.
In the US, we are also known
for our pioneering spirit.
It's things like
this that encourage
us to defy the odds of the
human capacity for engineering,
whether it's the Golden Gate
Bridge in my home of San
Francisco, the space
shuttle, and the Snackadium.
For those of you who
have not participated
in the annual
tradition, this is where
you make a giant structure out
of your Super Bowl party food.
Usually that's filled with
guacamole or pigs in a blanket
or whatever your favorite
Super Bowl party items are.
In all seriousness,
though, I wrote this book
because I was really
driven by this question.
What unites us as
eaters in America?
We are known for our diversity,
and without question, that
is one of our greatest
strengths as a country.
But it also can leave
us feeling like we're
so divided that nothing
could be said about us
as a country as a whole.
We're also very open-minded--
again, one of, I think,
our greatest strengths.
But it means that our food
culture is constantly changing.
It's a very unstable
set of norms
that are very different
from other cultures where
maybe the same types of
traditions and ways of eating
and recipes are passed down
from one generation to another.
So in the midst of all that,
though, as I mentioned,
I wanted to find
out what unites us
and what can be said about
American food culture.
So this book really
holds a mirror up
to our daily behaviors.
In talking with
Pete a little bit,
I have the sense that that
certainly came true for him.
And it really asks us to pull
the lens back and see the ways
that food is a really powerful
mirror for who we are on a much
deeper level as Americans.
Throughout my research, I found
that three core values thread
across our history as a people
and today shape our food
habits in ways that
are pretty stunning.
These three values are
work, freedom, and progress.
And they're so deeply
ingrained in our psyche,
as I describe, that
sometimes we don't even
realize how powerful
they are, how much they
affect our daily
relationships to food.
They are things, though,
that are very much part
of how we're trained in school.
And if you're like me, some of
the stuff is kind of abstract,
feels a little fuzzy
without any examples.
So we'll dive right in.
So with work, for
example, today in the US
we are taking less vacation
than at any point in the last 40
years.
We are outworking
even ourselves.
And that's saying a
lot because our work
ethic is a huge part
of our national brand
around the globe.
Today we work about
200 more hours per year
compared about a generation ago.
And all of that
time spent working
has led to bringing a lot
of food into the workplace.
Google, I would, say is
one of the best places
to be eating at the workplace,
but not everyone is so lucky.
And many of us have
been victim of what's
been called sad desk lunch.
Raise your hand if you've been
a victim of sad desk lunch.
[LAUGHTER]
How about sad desk breakfast?
Yes.
You know where you're
hunched over the keyboard.
You're kind of spewing
crumbs all over the place.
But our premium on
productivity, this
is such a huge part
of our self-worth.
It leaves us very
much feeling like we
have to eke out every bit of
efficiency throughout the day.
And it's very normal.
Everyone around you kind
of does it, so why not?
And the other way that
our working all the time
affects our food choices is,
it doesn't leave a lot of time
for other things.
Namely, we eat on the run.
"Gobble, gulp,
and go"-- this was
proposed by a European
traveler in the 1800s.
This person was observing
Americans and said,
hey, you know, wow, you guys
really just-- food is fuel.
You get on with it and
onto whatever else you've
got to do in your busy day.
And today, this is
more true than ever.
We, actually, as
Americans not only spend
the least amount of time of
any of the major developed
countries cooking food, we spend
the least time eating food.
So "gobble, gulp,
and go" is certainly
an apt name or characterization
of our food culture today.
We also snack more than
we ever did before.
There used to be
times where you ate
and times where you
didn't eat and places
that you ate and places
that you didn't eat.
And I don't know if any of you
have observed this as well,
but today all the
lines are blurred.
I recently saw a
woman in DSW-- that's
the shoe store--
with a hand submerged
in a bag of snap pea crisps.
That was a new one for me.
But today, we're eating--
most of us, about 90% of us--
will eat multiple
snacks per day.
And a lot of us have
the idea that, oh,
it's this mentality
that's been spread,
that it's healthier because
you kind of maintain
an even metabolism.
And that's great in principle,
but only about 7% of people
who snack eat snacks
instead of meals.
In reality, we're adding
it to everything else
we would normally eat anyway.
And as a country, we're
eating about 400 more calories
then about a generation ago.
So it's a little bit of
intention versus action.
Protein is at the heart
of so many of our snacks.
Lunchables, many of you probably
have seen Lunchables or eaten
Lunchables as a kid.
These have now been rebranded
as portable protein pack.
You can learn more at
proteinproteinprotein.com.
I'm not making that up.
[LAUGHTER]
All kinds of products
are adding protein.
Cheerios now has protein.
I recently saw protein water.
And it very much has to do
with this mindset of producing,
deliver deliverables,
and protein
is the fuel that's
going to get you
through everything on your
super, crazy, hectic, long list
of to-do items.
It's the macronutrient du jour.
And they're packing protein
into every bar imaginable, which
is a little silly in
reality because almost
no one in the United States
fails to get enough protein.
Freedom is the second
core value that
really shapes our food choices.
In the United States, we may
not realize how unusual this is,
but we have an
independence-oriented society
as opposed to an
interdependence-oriented
society.
I, Sophie, look at how
distinct, and unique,
and separate I am from others
around me, as opposed to sort
of part of a larger collective.
And what that results in is
all kind of interesting things
for our food habits.
I feel it is my
birthright as an American
to eat when I want,
how fast I want,
with or not with
whomever I want.
And when you walk up to
the Starbucks counter,
you are actually
joyously, intentionally
deviating from a prescribed box.
It's that meaningful.
It really is.
Anyone know what
this number means?
AUDIENCE: The different
number of drinks
you can get at Starbucks?
SOPHIE EGAN: It is.
It's also the
population of Kirkland.
[LAUGHTER]
Fun coincidence.
So yes, it is really a bold
statement about your identity,
that you are not
going to be getting
the same thing as the person
next to you in that line.
We have the same
kind of feeling--
I don't know how many of you
have had this yourselves where
if you order off the
menu, right, it's like, oh
that was like made just for me.
And that's, again,
very different from
if you're sharing from, perhaps,
a large stew or something
that is much more communal
around a table that
happens in other cultures.
So customization
and personalizing
our good experiences really
stems from this individualism.
We also share an affinity
for the Burger King
slogan, "Have it your way."
This is credited
sometimes with sort
of setting off the marketing
around a lot of this.
But in reality today, fast
casual chains and customize,
build your own assembly
line models like Chipotle
actually enable this
having it your way in ways
that never actually
happened at Burger King.
But we definitely-- that
message resonates with us.
We also, as I mentioned,
eat alone a lot
as a result of this.
See this guy?
This would never happen today.
This photo is
clearly pre-iPhones.
This is taken from 2000.
Because this is eating alone
today, with your iPhone, right?
You maybe check in.
You take a picture of
yourself or someone
else comments on what
they would have ordered
and what they're
currently eating
at the time, and all
sorts of other things.
Technology in a
fascinating way has really
enabled more alone eating
because you feel less alone.
40% of smartphone users actually
like eating by themselves
because it feels like a way
to catch up on social media
or read something.
So it's this fascinating
combination, I think,
of an ingrained, sort of a
long held value as Americans
with this new technology.
The last one is progress.
And we rightfully
are very proud of
our scientific breakthroughs.
Science and the
pursuit in general
of innovation or our
entrepreneurial spirit
is, again, one of our
greatest strengths.
But it affects our eating
in some strange ways.
Mainly, we are very
nutrient-centered when
we look at foods.
We look for the
label on a package
to sort of signify
that it's safe.
You can plow ahead.
Or oh, this means it's
bad, therefore banish it
at all costs.
It also leads to all
kinds of weird fad diets.
So we jump on these latest
bandwagons with great whimsy.
And we'll see a news headline
that really often misinterprets
the science that is
actually very rigorous, very
slow, may have results that
are something as unexciting
as we need more info.
But it's a lot less attention
grabbing to have a study
or to have a headline
about a study that says--
or, sorry, it's more
attention-grabbing to have
a headline with a study
saying new research says,
you know, broccoli
leads to blindness
as opposed to new study says
broccoli is still good for you.
That's not going to
get news attention.
So there's this reliance
on processed foods and food
labels, also the sort of
susceptibility to a lot
of the different fad
diets that are peddled.
And it's a humongous industry.
Lastly, this pride in
progress leads to all kinds
of novelty seeking.
So this quote from Vanessa Wong.
"You may never thought you
wanted a blank flavored chip.
But Pringles is
betting you're either
curious enough or powerless
enough to give it a try."
Anyone want to guess
what that flavor was?
Hot diggity dog.
A hot dog flavored chip.
These are what I describe
in the book as stunt food.
This is the retail equivalent.
And these are absolutely
powerful marketing strategies.
They often play on
the limited time
only, creating a false sense
of scarcity in the market.
You know, hurry in
now or your life
is ruined because you
didn't get the shamrock
shake in time or McRib.
Or Doritos Locos
tacos, as I mentioned,
are another great example.
So this is an incredibly
powerful food environment
that we're often swayed by.
It leads us very-- it means
it's a lot easier said
than done to just rely
on the commonsense notion
of everything in moderation.
So amidst this often daunting
food environment, the food
landscape, my hope is
really to empower readers
to gain a bird's eye
perspective on themselves
within this environment
and to start to call out
some of these marketing tactics
for what I feel they really
are, which is stunts.
And also to start
to take more control
over our eating habits, our
daily relationships to food.
And with that, I
hope that you'll
be left feeling more in the
driver's seat of your food
choices.
Hopefully, though, not actually
consuming those food choices
while in the driver's seat.
That's it.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
PETE: So what we're
going to do now
is a bit of moderated session.
I've prepared some
questions for Sophie,
which I'll go ahead and ask,
and she'll give us some answers.
And we'll leave
time for Googlers
to have questions at the end.
So we set up a mic over there.
And as soon as it's time,
I'll let y'all know.
Sound good?
So Sophie, you said
that our American values
that you chose to highlight are
work, freedom, and progress.
How do those affect what we eat?
SOPHIE EGAN: They aren't
things that have just
appeared all of a sudden.
And a lot of things have
But they're traits that go back
to our founding as a country.
And what I was aiming
to do with this book
was get us out of the mindset
of A, blaming individuals,
like you're lazy or you
don't have enough willpower
to resist, and really to get
us to look at root causes.
In the public health world, this
is considered looking upstream.
And it's saying,
well, what is actually
driving these food choices?
Not just individually, but the
powerful physical environments
of marketing but also
culturally-- what is normal?
What is being reinforced
to you on a daily basis
as something people do?
Because what's socially normal
and acceptable is often-- we
both shape it and
are shaped by it.
So these three-- work,
freedom, and progress--
we're continually
exhibiting them to others
and continually watching
others do those things as well.
Again, though, it's often
on a subconscious level.
PETE: So tell us a
little bit about what
you call fast casual.
There's a chapter
on it in the book.
Could you tell us
what that's about?
SOPHIE EGAN: Sure,
so fast casual,
I explain it as-- in the
story of the three bears,
it's like the just right.
You have fine dining
on one end, and you
have fast food on another
end, and fast casual
is essentially an in-between.
It's a higher level of quality
or at least higher perception
of quality.
Some of the most prominent
brands are Panera.
Chipotle, certainly,
has led the trend.
And there's been countless new
companies or new food brands
that call themselves like
Chipotle of whatever type
of cuisine.
So we now have pizzas
where you build your own.
You have endless noodle bowls
and other kinds of grain bowls.
And the whole point
being that it's
about the same amount
of time that you
would hope to get fast
food, grab and go,
but the sourcing is usually
more ethically-- something
you can feel a little
bit better about.
The core is much more appealing.
Usually people actually
will eat it there instead of
take it to go.
And it almost always
relies on what
I call the book "cheffing,"
which is what one Consumer
Insights researcher
actually refers
to when you're kind
of pointing at what
you want on the counter.
And it feels like you're
really participating
in the making of the food.
That goes a really long way
in how fresh and how valuable
we feel-- or how
much value we think
we're getting in whatever
dish we're getting.
PETE: So if we're so time
stressed that we're always
eating at our desk, how
come so many people go out
for brunch on Sunday?
SOPHIE EGAN: Yeah, I
found this fascinating.
Who in the audience
is a brunch goer?
Anyone?
Brunch?
Sorta.
Maybe brunch maker?
No.
OK.
So I just thought
it was interesting
that during the week we
go to extreme lengths
to minimize the amount of time
spent obtaining, preparing,
and consuming food, to the
point where we will actually
buy a microwaveable meal that
takes four minutes to microwave
instead of five minutes.
There's endless
delivery apps, right?
But on the weekend,
it's really the time
we put the pause button on.
And so many things
happen at brunch
that are different from
our normal weekday rhythms.
You're more likely
to cook yourself.
Actually among the
most searched recipes
online are
breakfast-type of foods.
You likely aren't
watching the clock.
So we kind of-- it's all
about the pursuit of the meal,
not getting through the
meal and onto whatever
else you need to do.
It's also one of the more
social meals that we have.
In the United States, actually
a lot of the social scientists
are finding that social
isolation in the US
has increased dramatically.
People report feeling that they
have fewer close ties than they
did about a year ago.
And so we're sort of
socially starving.
And I consider brunch a sign
of this like silent rebellion,
a kind of grabbing onto
something that is felt
as kind of a dying concept.
I mean, the dinner party
doesn't happen nearly as much
as it used to.
A lot of times I think it's
because the last minute bail
text, and that often also was
that very communal experience
of making and eating food
with other people, which
seems so simple.
But these concepts of
[INAUDIBLE] or conviviality,
as they're called,
they're dying.
So I feel like brunch
and all the things that
go with it are the antidote.
And they're very
much a sign of how
deprived we feel of these
more slow and social and real
food experiences.
PETE: So what recommendations do
have for Americans as a whole?
SOPHIE EGAN: Well, on
the individual level,
my hope is that people
can start to find
what works for
them to bring more
real food into their lives.
I don't think that
everybody's going
to start-- I'm not
suggesting that we
go back in time and everybody
make all of their food.
We're specialized.
That is the nature
of our economy.
But I think there
are opportunities
for people to have
more practice,
gain more culinary competence.
You know, in the kitchen, play
around with different foods.
What happens to them at
different temperatures?
What flavors go together?
Food literacy is a term
that I describe in the book
that I feel many
of us are lacking.
So find what works for
you to just bring that
into your routines on
a more regular basis.
I've seen some great
examples like #mealprepsunday
is a hashtag on
Instagram that has
got all kinds of great
ideas, you know, jar salads.
And you make them on
Sunday, and then you
have your lunches for the week.
Sunday is the time
that people don't
feel as strapped for time.
So it's more likely that
you'll eat your homemade meal
on Wednesday if you've
already made it.
A lunch bunch is this
great idea I saw.
Actually there was a campaign
called Not Sad Desk Lunch
that Food 52 ran.
And a lunch bunch was
this idea that you
and-- again, Googlers
maybe wouldn't
need to do this as much,
but others certainly-- you
find four friends or coworkers.
And you rotate
cooking for other.
So you only have to
cook one day a week.
But that means five lunches
that were made with love
and they're homemade.
Ideally, you'd then maybe
eat them together and kind of
have the strength in
numbers of saying we're
taking a real lunch break.
On the, I would say,
institutional level,
I would love for us to start
to ask employers to make it
more of a cultural
norm, just the simple--
the break that used to happen.
It actually does really
boost productivity.
And also though, seeing this
in the context of not just
workplaces but schools, I don't
know if this happened to you,
any of you growing up, but
kids get about 10 minutes
to scarf down a hot dog.
I don't understand how
we can have them trained
in that kind of
environment and go out
into the world with the
sense, oh, food matters.
It's mixed messaging.
So I would love to see
institutions like schools
as well start to
carve out more time
and place a greater
cultural emphasis on food.
PETE: Cool.
Thanks.
So what about us Googlers?
We've got access to
free food all day long.
What do you recommend for us?
SOPHIE EGAN: Well, the great
thing about working at Google,
I would say, in
terms of the food,
is it's very, very high quality.
And the people making
the food are exceptional.
I mean that not only in
terms of the quality,
and I should say,
full disclosure, I
work with many Google
food folks-- I don't know
if you know but Google
food actually follows
the menus of change principles
of healthy, sustainable menus,
which I am the director
of that initiative.
And that's with the Culinary
Institute of American
and Harvard School
of Public Health.
So in any case, there is just
a tremendous amount of thought
that goes into the
food at Google.
This is my way of saying
most of the things in here
have been curated
and prepared in ways
that are not the same as
everywhere else in the world.
Here, however, because
it is abundant and free,
it does create all kinds
of interesting habits.
We've heard of the
so-called Google 15.
Hopefully none of you
have succumbed to that.
Or you realize that
the food is still
going to be there tomorrow.
But it's very powerful.
I completely get it.
But there is also a
good number of folks
producing the food at
Google who are actually
behavioral economists.
I was getting into
the micro kitchen,
seeing some examples
where just to encourage
more mindful eating.
So that if you are
eating your three cookies
that no one I will
say in here ate,
if you are eating
those cookies, you're
doing so because
you're like, you
know, I really
want three cookies,
not that you went through
the day and all of a sudden
couldn't even recount what you
kind of mindlessly grazed on.
So if it's a treat,
really enjoy it.
Take a moment.
Maybe go outside.
Stare at the gorgeous view.
Think about the
flavor, whatever it
is that's going to make it more
of an intentional, purposeful
food experience.
And they're also doing
all kinds of things
to encourage you to make
healthy choices, the old fruit
basket with the fruit out
and beautiful display.
That actually is really
effective in getting people
to grab more fresh
fruits and vegetables.
So I would say know that
you're in good hands.
Know that there's a lot
of thought behind it
and it's not that you should
feel guilty for enjoying it,
but also that it should
be done with thought.
And I think the reason that
I hone in on sad desk lunch
is I think that's the ultimate
example of mindless eating.
And again, many
of us do it, but I
don't think it's the kinds
of ways of incorporating food
into our daily lives that feel
good or are very good for us.
PETE: So is there
anything we as a company
can do to help others?
SOPHIE EGAN: Well, yeah,
so one of the greatest
things I've seen at Google
is the teaching kitchens.
So have any of you taken
classes at the kitchen sink?
Awesome.
So I love that this
can happen, and I
would love to see Google
share the positive results
to the employees
with other employers.
Imagine not only at
Google, but let's
say you're an hourly worker
or low income workers,
if they could come home
with a meal prepared
for their family that
day or just learn
skills, whether it's for
grocery shopping or for cooking,
to sort of replicate
this type of model
where the employer
can-- Google, I think,
has a philosophy that employees
are the bridge to families.
And so if all the Googlers
have a lot of culinary literacy
and are very skilled
at cooking, then they
can share that not only
with their families,
perhaps with their
neighbors at the pot luck
and so on, and not
only, as I mentioned,
to try to get as
the larger culture
greater importance
on food but also
just that you can
sort of be ambassadors
for the skills
that you've gained
or for the ways that it's
maybe empowering you to make
more of your own meals
at home when you're not
inside of Google.
PETE: So next, you
recommend learning
to cook ourselves more.
And we have the teaching kitchen
called Kitchen Sink, which
we were just talking about.
We also have a big
mindfulness program.
In fact, they even combined
the two with a mindful cooking
class.
We put soda behind the frosted
glass on the lower shelf.
We hide the candy inside things.
You have to find the
candy to know where it is.
Is there something
else the company
could do to help
employees have a better
relationship with food?
Or is that enough?
SOPHIE EGAN: It's certainly
more than other employers.
Not all, but Google
is absolutely
a leader in that realm.
I think that the main area that
some companies are starting
to go in, I don't know the ins
and outs of Google's sourcing,
but is starting to use their
purchasing power in communities
to support the food grown in the
ways that matches their value.
So because Google feeds a
lot of people-- the same way
that a college or a university
or a hospital, these
are called high volume
food service settings--
they actually have tremendous
power on their growers.
And they can actually
work with whomever is
supplying the different foods.
They can select vendors that
have really high standards,
whether that's organic or
it's local or it's meat that's
raised without antibiotics
or whatever it might be.
But if their vendors aren't
exhibiting those practices
and they think
that in other ways
they're doing things
right, they can actually
give that feedback to them,
work together collaboratively,
to raise the bar for
their land management
practices, their water
usage, all of those things.
So I think that that's
not as much something
that necessarily employees
can do other than express
if that's of interest to you, if
you want to encourage your food
team to do that, I think that's
certainly a role that Google
can play-- this office can play
in the Pacific Northwest area,
and so on with the
different offices
that it has all over the world.
PETE: So I think I remember
you saying in the book
that diets don't work
because we end up always
gaining all the weight back.
So if diets don't work,
what's a good approach?
None at all?
SOPHIE EGAN: This is
such a tricky issue.
And it was in the news
quite a bit last week also.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SOPHIE EGAN: Yeah,
you probably saw that.
It's the "Biggest Loser," this
big study that corroborated
this data that I had cited.
And, I mean, there have been
many, many, many examples
of this, where,
unfortunately, most diets,
if they work in the
short term, they
don't work in the long term.
And unfortunately, this
just absolutely shocked me,
having been on a diet is often
one of the greatest predictors
for future weight gain.
And I find that
just incredibly sad
because obvious anyone
who's going on a diet
is trying to do the right thing.
The main issue
with most diets is
that they throw you out of
whack with, as I mentioned,
the everything in moderation.
So if you're banishing
entire food groups,
often a craving will
build over time,
and they find that a lot of
people who deprive themselves
of something for a
period of time, there's
like a way later
binging of that.
It doesn't mean that every
single person or that no one
can sustain a diet
in the long term.
It just means
generally speaking,
diets are extremely
difficult to sustain.
So the advice that
I give in general,
and I was very encouraged by
actually the latest dietary
guidelines-- the first time
ever, this is huge-- really
encourage people to develop
healthy eating patterns.
That seems like,
hmm, kind of how
is that different
from the word diet?
But it does.
It means that instead of having
really strict rules on yourself
or there's a lot of shaming
with diets, like you strayed,
therefore you must be punished.
It's this idea more of just,
OK, throughout your lifetime,
how can you develop routines?
It doesn't mean to the
same thing every day,
but in general for breakfast,
you eat whole grains and nut
butters and yogurt.
I don't know.
Fresh fruit.
You have sort of a group of
foods that collectively make up
a pattern that over your
life will basically give you
the best chance at not
just living long but living
a high quality of life.
And so I think the more that we
get away from instant results,
and a lot of the diets
are about how quickly
they're going to work-- there's
these kind of guaranteed.
Anything that
promises, guarantees,
like instant results is probably
just in itself those things
are a red flag.
It's very, very difficult,
but I feel like that the more
that you allow those occasional
kind of straying-- or again,
just the less rigid it is, the
easier it will be to follow.
And I actually found
a really fascinating--
so the US News and World
Report produces a best diets
list every year.
And last year paleo
diet, which, according
to our Google searches
is our most popular diet.
I think most of us believe
our Google searches reveal
a lot about who we are.
That was the most popular diet.
But it was ranked the
lowest of 35 diets
in terms of best
overall for your health.
That's pretty shocking, right?
The biggest reason it
said, well, for one,
it leads you to eat just
obscene amounts of meat.
But secondly, they said that
it's very hard to adhere to.
So again, that, I think, is
the biggest common thread
across different diets is
how frustrating it can be
and how difficult they
can be to maintain.
PETE: In the book
you talk a little bit
about an experiential CV.
Can you tell us a little
bit about that, what it is,
and how it applies to food?
SOPHIE EGAN: Sure.
Yeah, this was a
really fun finding.
It's this idea that the same
way that you might collect
seashells or shot glasses,
whatever you like to collect,
we aim to collect
life experiences.
So in the same way you kind of
accrue professional experiences
for your CV or
your resume, people
want to feel that they've
lived a full life.
It's this bucket
list idea, right?
And it leads us to choose foods
like Doritos Locos tacos, stunt
foods, because it
feels like sort
of checking a box on
your list of like,
I have lived a full life.
I ate a bacon sundae or
drank-- ate a bacon sundae.
I had to think about
that for a second.
And so you'll will
even choose things
that you think will
be less enjoyable
but that are more
memorable and distinct.
So for example, they did a study
of people going on vacation
and found that they actually
would choose staying in an ice
hotel over like a really
warm, pleasant beach vacation
because you'd be able
to brag about it.
It would feel probably
easier to recall compared
to other things you've
experienced in your life
unless you live in an ice hotel.
And this affects this pension
we have for seeking out novelty
in our foods and collecting.
And actually,
interestingly, Taco Bell,
in marketing the Doritos Locos
taco, really played to that.
They must have seen
the same research.
Because the timeline
was "Live Mas."
And it was this idea of we've
got the way with the DLT
for you to live mas.
So they're offering the
solutions to something that,
again, probably subconsciously,
but most of us--
I certainly want to
live a full life.
So Doritos Locos tacos for all.
PETE: So a number of years
ago, I got "Muscle & Fitness"
magazine, and they
said you can only
absorb like 20 grams
of protein per meal.
So the recommendation
was that you
have five or six small meals
or really big snacks instead
of like three big meals.
Is that a good
idea or a bad idea?
SOPHIE EGAN: So
I certainly would
steer clear of giving specific
dietary advice to anyone.
And I'm actually
not a nutritionist.
But I can say that
our behavior shows
that it's not really working
as it maybe is intended to.
Because the snack is defined as
something to supplement a meal.
And most likely it's
complementing the meals,
as I mentioned.
I think it certainly
can maintain a higher
energy for some people compared
to, say, like the quote,
unquote like "gut bomb."
You skip breakfast and
then you eat a giant lunch.
So there's probably definitely
some at least anecdotal
illustrations of where
that's a better approach.
But it's just the
difference-- in reality,
we're eating so much
more altogether.
And the other thing is
a lot of these products
are very expensive.
So you mentioned protein.
A lot of the products, your
total budget might go up.
Or you might feel
like, oh, I can't
buy as many fresh foods because
of my huge KIND Bar budget,
just speaking personally.
So no, I'm certainly
guilty of that myself.
But I think we have this
mindset of-- for any athletes
out there, the term is bonking.
Like, oh god, I
don't want to crash.
I have to get through
all this stuff.
And the beef jerky in my
purse or the Nature Valley bar
in the car console is
going to get me through.
And I think we need to
calm down a little bit
about that side of things.
And for people, if they feel
a lot better when they're
eating a few snacks
throughout the day,
I'm not going to tell people
specifically not to do that.
But I would encourage
people to actually
be honest about-- are they
skipping meals altogether?
And also the other
thing I want to add
is it's probably not
that much fun to be
eating on your own schedule.
It sort of goes to the social
eating that I was describing.
Because if you're
eating in your car
and at your desk and
all those things,
maybe metabolically speaking
you're a little bit better off,
but your happiness might
suffer because you're not
eating with friends or family.
And this might sound kind
of fuzzy, but it's real.
Happiness is one
of the-- there's
all these different happiness
researchers out there, which
sounds like a really fun job.
But they have found that
actually social connectedness
is one of the single greatest
predictors of happiness.
And I don't think I'm
overstating the importance
of social eating.
PETE: So something that
happens to me-- it's probably
a little bit unique, but maybe
not as unique as I think--
is I'll come home
at night and my wife
has already fed the kids.
Guess what?
You're on your own.
Nothing's made for me.
So I'm going to have to
make something for myself.
So for people like me
who end up coming home
and have to make
something for themselves
and don't know ahead of time,
so they can't like run out
and grab something fresh?
Do you have any good ideas?
I've been doing like
pasta and sandwiches,
but I've been doing so
many pasta and sandwiches
that I'm ready for other ideas.
SOPHIE EGAN: Yeah, definitely.
AUDIENCE: Sad home dinner.
PETE: Exactly.
[LAUGHTER]
SOPHIE EGAN: [INAUDIBLE].
I know, that's a new one.
PETE: It's not that sad
because I can sit with my iPad
and connect with my friends.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Sad home dinner.
SOPHIE EGAN: He's feeling
really connected to others.
No, that's a great question.
And this definitely-- I think
you're probably not alone.
One of the more
interesting things
that I found-- or more
surprising things I found
in the book-- was this
family dinner a la carte,
where even families who
are eating together,
over half of families are
eating different things
from each other, different
dietary preference or very real
medical concerns.
But it's sort of a short
order cook situation, right?
And it leads actually
to many families
eating more prepared foods,
cooking less, et cetera.
As for your
particular situation,
I think there are things that
actually relate to the meal
prep Sunday idea.
So you could make a bowl or
make a whole batch of quinoa
or farrow or any
kind of whole grain
like a wild rice or something,
a brown rice, on Sunday
and make it in different ways.
Maybe you make a wrap one
night or the next night
you just have it as a bowl.
I also feel personally
like any number of meals
can be built around an avocado.
So I just always keep avocados.
Because I might make an avocado
toast with some kind of-- all
I have at home is
bread, cheese, avocado.
And you add some sriracha.
My husband really
likes the sriracha.
Like, that's dinner.
So keeping some of those
things like on hand
at the beginning of
the week, but then so
that you don't
feel like, oh, I'm
eating the same thing
every day, having
some of those extra items
that you can build in
in different layers.
And I also would say
that like sriracha,
having any number
of sauces and flavor
enhancers at home
that you really like,
dijon mustard actually
goes a long way,
can definitely help when
you don't feel like,
oh, I can rush out
to the grocery store.
Or maybe you can't even
predict that you're
going to need to be eating
sad home dinner that night.
PETE: Awesome.
Thanks.
That will help a lot.
SOPHIE EGAN: I'm sure.
PETE: So the next question, so I
think I showed you in the micro
kitchen beforehand how we have
those little candy jars like
with the rooster, and you
have to realize it's there,
and open it up, and reach
down to grab the little packet
of fun size M&Ms. Is
that helping or hurting?
I mean, if we have a craving for
M&Ms and we're just not getting
the M&Ms that we need, is that
going to make us binge later?
SOPHIE EGAN: The M&Ms
that you need, yes.
You need those
M&Ms. I don't know.
I'm sure there are some
unintended consequences of some
of these little tricks.
These come out of--
most of the work
is Brian Wansink, is this
really fascinating researcher
at Cornell Food
and Brand Lab who's
come up with a lot of the
things like the frosted glass.
Or if you put
something opaque, like
you have to take that
extra step and, oh, hmm,
how do I get into this thing?
And take off the top, as opposed
to if it's just sitting out.
From reading his
research, I haven't
seen him necessarily
describe in great detail
the kind of unintended
consequences
that you're wondering about.
But I would say
psychologically it
sounds like there can be
some sort of built up,
like, I know that's in the jar.
So if I were Google food, I
might mix up what's actually
in the jar so that you aren't
always wondering about the M&Ms
that you need.
Instead maybe one day, it's like
apples or it's fruit leather
or it's nuts.
And instead of it being the
thing that you can't have,
sort of tempting
you or taunting you,
if it were different things,
then you'd just be like,
oh it's the mystery box.
Back to work.
That's not a very
helpful answer.
Sorry.
PETE: OK, so I think it's
time for us to open up
the mic for Googlers.
So we have a mic
set up over here.
So please make a line
and ask questions.
AUDIENCE: We also have
Mike setting up the mic.
SOPHIE EGAN: Mike
setting up the mic.
AUDIENCE: In the
blurb for your talk,
one of the things
that was mentioned
was gluten free,
which made me think
it seems to me that
there's been an explosion
over the last couple of decades
of people self-diagnosing food
restrictions.
The gluten-free
thing is probably
the most extreme where there
is this actual condition called
celiac disease, and people who
have it can't deal with gluten.
But there's 10 or 100
times as many people
as have celiac disease that have
decided by themselves, largely,
without the aid of
medical professionals,
that they're gluten sensitive.
And you see the same thing with
people deciding on their own
they're lactose intolerant
or various other things.
I wondered what you make
of this and why we seem
to be overwhelmed by this now.
SOPHIE EGAN: Yeah.
Thank you for the question.
It's a great question.
It comes up a lot.
I actually have a
piece coming out
very soon about this very
topic because I've been asked
about it a number of times.
There definitely is a lot
of self-diagnosis going on.
The numbers, you're very close.
It's about 1% of people have
celiac disease, very severe
autoimmune condition that
damages the small intestine.
About roughly 7%-- though
they really don't know--
appear to have non-celiac
gluten sensitivity.
Fully a third of Americans
are trying to avoid gluten.
And that really speaks
to what you're saying,
I think, in terms of this
getting really blown out
of proportion.
The other concern
I have is that it
is miss-- it's kind of
like misappropriating
the real cause of gluten free.
Because the real
cause of gluten free
is that this is a real sickness.
And most people now
in the wake of a lot
of these different diet
books and the whole segment
of the grocery store
that's been opened up,
it's become about weight loss.
And if I eat gluten
free, then I won't
have these stomach problems.
And I'll lose
weight, and I'll have
more energy and all of
the different things
that are associated with that.
There is not scientific
data to support the idea
that gluten-free diet
makes you lose weight.
And the way that I
interpret what's going on
is a couple of things.
First to the
self-diagnosis point,
I see a lot of that
with-- what does
really going on a
gluten-free diet mean to you?
If you are all of a sudden more
conscious in general of what
you're eating because
you're checking labels,
maybe you're slowing
down, maybe you're
checking the portion size
or things that you before
didn't give another thought
to-- there's definitely actually
some science that shows that
the people have better results
merely when they're paying
more attention to whatever
it is that they're eating.
Second is that if
going gluten free
means you're eating less
cookies and less chips
and you're drinking less
beer and you're also
eating healthier things,
then you probably
feel like a million bucks.
And a lot of people do
report some of these results
and miss-attribute
it to the gluten.
I'm not saying
all the people who
feel that way don't have
non-celiac gluten sensitivity.
But it's a real murky
area, particularly
with that one, the non-celiac
gluten sensitivity.
Not that much is
known about it yet.
And there isn't really
a way to test for it.
But I did find it
very interesting
that Celiac Disease
Foundation actually
is pretty clear on their
website about this.
They say do not self-diagnose.
Please consult with
your doctor before going
on a gluten-free diet.
And that seems to be a message
that's getting overlooked.
A lot of people are OK, now
I'm gluten free for life
or whatever it is.
And a lot of it also spreads
from one person to the next.
I describe in the
book this phenomenon
that gluten free is not
the first example of this,
but there's this diet
evangelism, a kind of "join me"
mentality of whatever
it is that you're part.
And it doesn't mean, again, that
some of the people genuinely
really need to be on that diet.
But for the proportion
of the population that's
paying attention to it,
it's just the latest example
what I describe also in
the book as selling absent.
It's valuing foods
based on what they lack.
And we saw this with fat free.
And what happens, unfortunately,
is that all these products
get reformulated.
And you have to replace
the gluten with something.
So do you ever look
at the ingredient list
of a lot of
gluten-free products?
They're excruciating.
And they have all kinds of
potato starch and tapioca
powder and whatnot that are not
any better, and in some cases,
are actually worse than
the original product.
And again, this
happened with fat free.
So it really depends.
I think people
have been surprised
how long this trend has lasted.
Part of it is that
a lot is still
unknown about digestive health.
Gut health in general is
becoming a much more mainstream
topic.
Self-diagnosis and then
also just that more products
are available than ever before.
And the market always
responds to these things.
So we have to, I hope, keep
a little bit of a level
head for those of us--
I, personally, do not
have sensitivity to gluten, so
I think we need to keep a level
head about a lot of this.
PETE: Thank you.
Do we have more questions?
AUDIENCE: I have a couple
small comments and then
one larger question.
SOPHIE EGAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: So one comment
is you were talking about
with fast casual dining, this
idea of like you're picking out
your food.
Have you heard of
the IKEA effect?
You mentioned behavioral
economics earlier,
and this is--
SOPHIE EGAN: No,
tell me about that.
AUDIENCE: Well, so briefly, the
name just comes from the fact
that when people assemble
their own IKEA furniture,
they tend to value
it more highly
than had they
purchased it premade.
And this gets people around
the fact that generally it's
made of, you know,
MDF or particle board
or whatever else, right?
But they're still very proud
of their IKEA furniture.
Similarly, my burrito
bowl at Chipotle,
I care about it more
because I have hand-selected
each and every single bean.
SOPHIE EGAN: You
were a participant.
Exactly.
AUDIENCE: The other
thing that I wanted
to comment on very quickly
was on the gluten-free stuff.
I have a friend who has celiacs,
and he's commented both like
on the pros and cons of this.
He said, and one
thing that's great
is I can go to every restaurant
that my friends go to
and find something I could eat.
He said, on the
other hand, no one
thinks I have a disease anymore.
They think I'm just
like a fad follower
even though I've known I've
had celiacs for 15 years.
So he said that was
also really frustrating.
SOPHIE EGAN: That's
a great point.
AUDIENCE: My bigger
comment and question
is one of the things you
talked about a lot with work
in particular was this
time crunch, that everyone
feels very rushed all the time.
I think it's actually
interesting to note
that in the US, it's
not only that we spend
200 more working hours per year
than we did 10 or 20 years ago.
SOPHIE EGAN: About
a generation ago.
AUDIENCE: A generation ago.
But that we actually do so far
more than any other country
in the entire first world.
We just work way more,
and as you noted,
have to spend a lot
less time cooking
and eating than other first
world nations, similarly.
Do you think that the
problem here is not
simply one that can just be
dealt with in food policy
but is simply a kind of
national epidemic of how
we view productivity and
work-life balance in general?
SOPHIE EGAN: Thank you for
that comment and a question.
I absolutely think it
is that larger picture.
And I get into this a little
bit in the book about how
linked a lot of the policies are
in other progressive indicators
that really affect eating.
So for example,
also in that list
of all the major
developed countries,
we're the only one with
no paid maternity leave.
And there's a whole bunch of
different social indicators
or social measures
where what I'm
seeing it's really interesting
is actually employers
are sort of-- I this is
not the point of the book,
but I'm seeing a
lot of different--
especially in like Silicon
Valley type companies,
where they're saying there
isn't a national policy of this,
so I'm going to give six
months of paternity leave.
There's some companies in
Germany where they actually
shut off email after 6:00 PM.
It just doesn't work.
And they said, you know what?
As a country, we want
people to go home
and be with their families.
We want them to be well-rounded.
I also am really
fascinated by have
we become less interesting?
Do people do less
hobbies because they--
it's sort of more
one-dimensional.
We're so specialized and
so deep into the work.
I'm like, well,
learn a language.
I don't know, take
a ceramics class
or just play with your
kid or whatever it is,
sort of having more dimensions.
I'm wondering how that--
I don't have the evidence.
I don't know who's
studying that.
Travel [? board ?]
or the leisure people
out there who--
magazines and things,
but that I definitely
think is very interesting.
And I'm very intrigued
to see what levers
can be pulled because this is
not about individually you suck
because all you do is work.
It's our individual choices
as not only with food
but with how much you work.
I mean, I work all the time
because I feel I have to.
I have these deadlines to meet.
And I have these
things I have to do,
not because I love just
working all the time.
So I think that the only
way this is going to change
is when there are policies
that make it, again,
the same way with food, that
make it not only socially
acceptable but socially normal
to sign off at a certain time
or to eat during the workday,
as I mentioned, carving out
that time for yourself, so
whatever those things might be.
And I'm staying tuned.
PETE: Let's all give Sophie a
great welcome and a thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SOPHIE EGAN: Thank you, guys.